[Music]
it's it's fascinating to see what like
battle royale games and they like it's
it's crazy like maybe like a year ago we
wouldn't even say battle royale games it
was just like a mod and then another mod
that game right now it's considered an
almost yeah I mean I have helped along
the way but the I started off as a mod
and went to become a again another game
mode in another game and then eventually
with battlegrounds it kind of became a
Dillon game you can compare it to like
something that like like team deathmatch
for instance that has become a staple in
every most shooters and not even just
shooters like a lot of different game
genres but like it's almost like this
mode that people are expecting in the
future sure I mean no that's why I
always thought when I first didn't they
invented it was that it could be that
kind of mode eventually where it's just
like as you said capture flag or you
know king of the hill it's it's that
type of game mode that it's just a new
game mode and yeah I think it's it's
flexible not to be tough it's seeing
like GTA put in their moto Wars which
was kind of a battle royale type thing
and you know I remember playing like the
first GTA of the second GTA with friends
in an office like top-down and like you
know just one guy would always run you
over a keeper they find a spawn and you
know seeing then a game of that sky is
kind of you know putting in a game mode
that like I helped create is is is
humbling you know it's it but it's great
to see the genre grow the way it has and
you know a new and interesting spins are
coming out you know the Darwin project
just released within the director mode
so you know it's it's great to see kind
of different people's takes on a you
know a very simple concept for pub G
specifically how do you kind of like
make it like relevant like five years
from now like what are some of the main
tenets that you're trying to lose did
yes as you said we're adding new maps
new vehicles new content that and that's
one way to you know continually improve
the battlegrounds that people fight on
but also we have our custom game system
and their event system that we just
launched up especially with custom games
it's almost like modding light where you
know we let players
mess around with the game and then try
to create their own interesting game
modes it's the zombies game mode came
from a Korean streamer who used our
custom game system so that's where I see
you know you know a big part of our
future is supporting you know players
creativity and and letting players
make games within our game and being a
platform rather than just a game we were
saying like that the five biggest games
in the last five or 10 years or 20 years
of being from moths you know Meeks yes
go dota they're all essentially from
mods right and I think it's because
modding gives us like a freedom to to
create and take those risks and kind of
do something that basically you know
that people aren't asking for but just
something you want to play that's what I
wanted to do what I wanted to make about
l'oréal that I wanted to play right and
yeah I think that that's freedom to
create whatever you want is a big
advantage than modding gives people
[Music]
you